is Mike Johnson the most conservative
politician in America no no he's not
because I think we would have to give
that title right now to xiin Ping the
Chinese Communist dictator came to visit
uh California specifically came to visit
San Francisco and chairman XI with his
very brief visit to San Francisco has
done more to clean up that city than any
politicians liberal or conservative in
other parts of the of America seem to
have done in decades San Francisco
absolute disaster druggies criminals on
the street shooting up dying of exposure
breaking into cars wealthy people
fleeing the city burglaries vandalism
all that she shows up and right before
he gets there all the bums are gone the
crime is cleaned up all of the broken
windows they're all fixed and you could
basically eat off the sidewalks very
very very
impressive some conservative
commentators were dismayed at the
pictures from She's visit and I
understand why because the Streets of
San Francisco look like they're the
streets of Beijing they were just
Chinese red flags everywhere and it's a
little
spooky I don't think we want to become a
vassal state of China That's and I don't
want to I don't want it to seem like I'm
singing she's Praises just because the
Chinese Communists are better than
American liberals at many many things
that's damning with faint praise okay
I'm not saying that's
ideal but there are even some
conservative commentators who say look
at this these images from the Streets of
San Francisco and get ready that's what
America is going to look like soon
enough and the fact
is they're basically right about that it
sounds like one of those hyperbolic
conspiracy theorist you know
fear-mongering catastrophist lines get
pretty soon we're going to just turn
into communist China and chairman she's
going to be ruling us with an iron fist
but what what is going to happen what's
going to happen there there at the
present trajectory of American Decline
and Chinese Ascent two things can happen
the most likely thing is that we're
going to have a global
war
because most of the time as the Harvard
political scientist Graham Allison has
showed when uh
Rising Powers confront great Powers
three quarters of the time in recent
history that has led to a major conflict
a war so likely that's what's going to
happen and then the question is can the
United States win a war right now can we
fight a war I'm not convinced that we
can we're extremely divided the libs
have turned our military into a critical
race Theory uh sexual identity struggle
session so I don't know that that's a
great idea the American people are are
extraordinarily divided even on basic
first principles and we're bogged down
in all sorts of Wars of Empire around
the world that don't directly affect our
our Vital national interests so if some
of our Vital interests were threatened
Say by a rising China we would probably
be scrambling to do anything about it
also our military was degraded over
eight years of Barack Obama and and
certainly neglect under Joe Biden so
that that's probably the first thing
that would happen but then even let's
say we somehow avoid war or or the war
turns out fine in the
end what will happen is if China manages
to keep on its path and if America
doesn't reverse the decline that
decadence and liberalism have put us in
then China will be a global power we'll
have a first a multi-polar world with
the United States and China as two of
the great powers and then you know
Empires are born and they rise and they
fall if
America we hope it doesn't happen but if
America does really decline then we will
be subject to the same kind of cultural
imperialism that we have subjected the
rest of the world
to and that's not good uh we don't want
that I I don't want red Chinese flags
anywhere in the United States other than
for a few days to clean up the city of
San Francisco but that's not something I
look forward to well if that's not
something you look forward to if you
don't look forward to decline if you
don't look forward to cultural
imperialism and outright Invasion when
you don't have any borders then you have
to support an agenda that will make
America great again then you have to
support an agenda not just of small
government not just
of global liberalism and and running
every single country around the world
you have to support an agenda that is
specifically oriented toward National
greatness in the United States and very
few people seem willing to do that right
now go to goodranchers.com use promo
code nolles there's a lot at stake this
November so don't be chicken and shop at
the grocery store like usual instead you
should see food no that one I added that
one in there go get good ranchers it's
it's great it's even better than my meat
puns head on over and do not miss their
Black Friday your way sale which is now
live this November get your favorite
meat free for a year that's right one
year of free steak salmon chicken or
bacon when you subscribe to any box
right now better yet when you subscribe
to any box on goodranchers.com you not
only get a free gift of meat up to 480
bucks you also get $15 off with code NES
I don't know how they do it the meat is
exceptionally high quality I I've never
seen anything like it I love it I eat it
multiple times a week when I can I'm not
being sent on the road and kept away
from my good ranchers I don't know how
they keep the prices so low I don't know
how the meat is All American Meat I
don't know how they're giving you free
meat for a year I don't know how any of
their finances work but their financial
confusion is your benefit go get it
right now it is I could not possibly
recommend good ranchers highly enough go
to goodranchers.com use code NES your
free meat 15 bucks off number one place
to get All-American beef pork chicken
and seafood B promo code nolles kwes
goodranchers.com good ranchers American
Meat delivered right now go to
medishare.com Michel as a dailywire
listener you are not just informed you
are engaged and handsome and pretty you
value freedom and personal
responsibility that's why you need to
check out Medishare Medishare is a
community- based approach to healthcare
that lines up with what you believe in
your views matter and Medishare allows
you to take your Healthcare dollars and
not use them for medical procedures that
don't line up with your beliefs
Medishare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of
400,000 Believers committed to caring
and sharing with one another members
save up to 50% or more on their monthly
healthcare costs and member satisfaction
surveys show that they like Meda share
much more than health insurance why
because it works for a limited time
dailywire listeners will receive a $150
gift card when they join Medishare to
find out more go to medishare.com m i
AEL that is Medishare meedi
share.com terms and conditions apply
here's a here's a story that might
tickle the conspiracy theorists among
you you know those awful crazy
conspiracy theorists who are usually
almost always right about everything in
the last few years we say the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is six months
but the conspiracy theorists and the
religious people and the conservatives
and Pope
Francis has just signed off on a new
document an official document from the
Vatican reaffirming that Catholics
cannot be
Freemasons what why can't Catholics be
freem wait hold on Pope Francis he's
supposed to be a big lib and a Kumbaya
and some people accuse him of being a
Freemason what do you mean Catholics
can't be Freemasons hold on the
Freemasons are still around I know
there's some old secret society that I
heard about in some movies but I I
they're that real and why does the
Vatican even care about
this there are all sorts of reasons the
Freemasons are a real group it's not
just something that comes out of
conspiracy theory YouTube videos uh the
Freemasons have largely been opposed to
the Catholic church in particular over
the centuries that part is true there
are lots of conspiracy theories about
the Freemasons some of those conspiracy
theories are true some of them seem
somewhat dubious to me but the reason
that Pope Francis is reaffirming the
consistent and traditional catholic
teaching that Catholics can't be
Freemasons is much more basic and it's a
lesson for all of us no matter what you
think your religion or political views
are the basic reason that Catholics
can't be Freemasons is because
Freemasonry is a sort of religion unto
itself that's the most basic reason
Freemasonry has its own particular
conception of God Freemason masonry has
its own particular rights and rituals it
even has burial rights Freemasonry has
its own particular conception of mankind
and his role in the cosmos Vis A God
whether the Freemasons would call God
God or use a different term to refer to
God it's just a different it's just a
different religion and you cannot
simultaneously be a member of two
contrary religions you cannot
simultaneously
believe contradictory
things you cannot simultaneously serve
two Gods you can't do it I mean this has
been true since the origin the Advent of
Christianity and in fact since the
Advent of faith in the Old Testament
since since Abraham comes around and
says no we're going to give up all that
Pagan stuff because the true God my God
has told me that he is the one true God
and he's greater than all the other
gods you can't you can't do it I mean it
goes back to to Aristotle's law of
non-contradiction you can't simultaneous
things that are
simultaneously uh pardon things that are
mutually contradictory cannot
simultaneously be true that's just a
fact and a I think a lot of people need
to examine that because people generally
hold all sorts of different views
especially in a pluralistic country many
of which conflict with one another so
the question you have to ask is what do
you ultimately believe where is your
ultimate devotion where does that
lie and in modern pluralistic countries
we just try to push that question off
and we say no you can believe all sorts
of contradictory things me sorts of fall
part of groups just just don't think too
deeply about it but that's not possible
and even even a pope who many refer to
as a liberal is pointing that out man
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel we'll see
you next time